I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hello. Hello and to love's eternal glory. Oh, lady. We should tell people this is the first podcast that we are recording in 2022. The other ones you've been listening to this year. We recorded before the new
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重播播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。大家好。大家好，致爱永恒的荣耀。哦，天哪。我们应该告诉大家，这是我们在2022年录制的第一个播客。你们今年一直在听的其他节目。我们在新年之前就已经录好了。
year. This is our first one back after our vacations. We are back. We are semi-rested. We're also semi-back. I am back in my closet. You are. You are in the studio. Oh, guys, there are some stricter protocols here at the beginning of 2022. So I let Angela have the studio. Me and Sam. What's up, Sam? Hi, everybody. Aw. Hey, Sam. Cassie and I are over here on Zoom. Hi, ladies. Hi. I will point out, you guys, Jenna, is that a ginormous plant in your podcast closet? It is. Do you notice Cassie's got a plant over her shoulder as well? I guess when you podcast from home, you need a plant. That's totally a coincidence.
这是我们假期回来后的第一期节目。我们回来了。我们半休息状态。我们也半复出了。我又回到了我的衣帽间。你确实是。你在录音室里。哦，伙计们，2022年初这里的规章制度更严格了。所以我让安吉拉用了录音室。我和萨姆。萨姆，怎么了？大家好。啊。嘿，萨姆。我和卡西在这边的Zoom上。嗨，女士们。嗨。我要指出，大家，詹娜，你播客衣帽间里那是株巨大的植物吗？是的。你注意到卡西的肩膀上也有一株植物吗？我想当你从家里做播客时，你需要一株植物。这纯粹是个巧合。
Sam has a little Christmas tree. Damn it. Lady, are you the only one without a plant? I'm plantless. Which is so crazy because you're the plant tracker. I love plants, guys. I guess I'm going to have to start traveling with my own plant. I'm going to be that lady. You know how you see people that travel always with a pet? Maybe I'm going to be the lady that's like, hey, do you see that lady with the little tiny succulent in her lap on the plane? I would love to travel with you as old ladies where you just clutch a tiny succulent the whole time. That's amazing.
萨姆有一棵小圣诞树。该死。女士，难道你是唯一一个没有植物的人吗？我没有植物。这太疯狂了，因为你是植物追踪者。我喜欢植物，伙计们。我想我以后得带着我自己的植物去旅行了。我要成为那种女士。你知道怎么看到有人旅行总是带着宠物吗？也许我要成为那种女士，就像，嘿，你看那个飞机上膝盖上抱着一个小多肉植物的女士吗？我很乐意和你们一起作为老太太去旅行，一路上就紧紧抓着一小盆多肉植物。太神奇了。
You guys, I should share with you that for Christmas, Jenna and I exchanged gifts. I got her some cozy pajama pants and she got me a succulent throw pillow. It looks like a giant succulent, but it's a cozy pillow. It really does. I brought it home and Isabel said, Mom, is that pillow a succulent? And I was like, yes, yes, it is, Isabel. Oh my God. You guys, Sam just brought me a plant. Hey! Wait, Cassie, can you get a picture? Cassie, you need to get in this picture with your plant. Okay, Sam, you hold up your tree. Ready? Here we go. One, two, three.
伙计们，我应该告诉你们，圣诞节时，詹娜和我互送了礼物。我送了她一些舒服的睡裤，她送了我一个多肉植物抱枕。它看起来像一个巨大的多肉植物，但它是一个舒服的抱枕。真的挺像。我把它带回家，伊莎贝尔说，妈妈，那个抱枕是多肉植物吗？我就说，是的，是的，它是，伊莎贝尔。哦，天哪。伙计们，萨姆刚刚给我带了一株植物。嘿！等等，卡西，你能拍张照片吗？卡西，你需要和你的植物一起拍这张照片。好了，萨姆，你举起你的树。准备好了吗？我们开始。一，二，三。
That is amazing. Well, you know, listen, we might have some protocols that keep us apart, but we're enjoying plants together. You guys, that's something. It's something. It's huge. I'll take it. Should we get into this episode? We really should because there's a lot of fun stuff to discuss. This is the promotion. It is season six, episode three. It is written by Jen Salada, directed by Jen Salada. And here is your summary.
太棒了。好吧，你知道，听着，我们可能有一些让我们分开的规矩，但我们在 一起享受植物。伙计们，这是一回事。这是一回事。这太重要了。我接受。我们应该开始看这一集吗？我们真的应该开始，因为有很多有趣的东西要讨论。这就是升职。这是第六季第三集。由詹·萨拉达编剧，詹·萨拉达导演。以下是你的剧情简介。
Michael and Jim's managerial power struggle intensifies when David Wallace reveals that they don't have enough money to give everyone in the office their yearly raises. So he leaves it up to the co-managers to determine who gets a raise. Meanwhile, Pam tries to get people to give her money instead of traditional wedding gifts. That storyline really cracked me up. It did me too. All right. Fast fact number one, I have a location breakdown. I thought you would. You might be thinking, wait, they didn't go anywhere on location.
当大卫·华莱士透露办公室里没有足够的钱给每个人发年度加薪时，迈克尔和吉姆的管理权力斗争加剧了。因此，他把决定谁能加薪的任务留给了联席经理们。与此同时，帕姆试图让人们给她钱，而不是传统的结婚礼物。那个故事线真的让我笑翻了。我也是。好的，趣味事实一，我有一个外景细分。我料到你会这么想。你可能会想，等等，他们没有去任何外景。
Please tell me your location breakdown is Jim's glass cube. It is, lady. Is it really? Well, we got a bunch of fan questions, including from Tara Jade L in South Australia. Can we please talk about the layout of the office changing? Because I don't think it's ever mentioned. A new office just appears for Jim to move into that was never there before. And from Soul C in Taiwan, what was involved in making Jim's office? Did they break down the wall behind Kevin's desk to make space?
请告诉我你的外景细分是吉姆的玻璃方块。正是如此，女士。真的吗？嗯，我们收到了很多粉丝的问题，包括来自南澳大利亚的塔拉·杰德·L。我们能谈谈办公室布局的变化吗？因为我觉得从来没有人提过。一个吉姆搬进去的新办公室就这样凭空出现，以前从来没有。来自台湾的索尔·C说，建造吉姆的办公室涉及什么？他们是砸掉了凯文办公桌后面的墙来腾出空间吗？
And Molly S from Arkansas says, how long did this process take? Did it slow down the shooting at all? See, lots of questions. Lots of questions. I'm going to have to agree with Tara Jade. That's true. Jim is just suddenly in a tiny glass cube in the office and no one says anything. No one says, where did this come from? I know. I would have loved just one talking head where someone was like, what the hell? I know.
来自阿肯色州的莫莉·S说，这个过程花了多长时间？它有没有放慢拍摄速度？看，很多问题。很多问题。我不得不赞同塔拉·杰德的观点。确实如此。吉姆突然就出现在办公室的一个小小玻璃方块里，没有人说什么。没有人说，这东西是从哪儿来的？我知道。我只想要一个单人访谈，里面有人说，搞什么鬼？我知道。
Like, you know, who would have been perfect is Ryan. Ryan being like, what the hell? Jim's glass box took over the whole corner of the office. I agree. Well, Jim's office was actually a pretty simple addition that was installed over the weekend. Randy Cordray shared with us that this is because we were able to build all the walls in our scenery mill, which was across the street from our studio lot. Michael Gallenberg designed them. They were built by our construction coordinator, Tim James.
就像，你知道，谁会是完美的呢？瑞安。瑞安会说，搞什么鬼？吉姆的玻璃盒子占了办公室的整个角落。我同意。嗯，吉姆的办公室实际上是一个相当简单的增建，在周末就安装好了。兰迪·科德雷和我们分享说，这是因为我们能够把所有的墙都在布景厂建造好，布景厂就在我们制片厂地块的街对面。迈克尔·加伦伯格设计了它们。它们是由我们的施工协调员蒂姆·詹姆斯建造的。
And then the walls were installed pretty quickly. They did arrange our shoot schedule so that we didn't shoot inside Jim's office until later in the week. This was mostly so that set dressing could decorate it. Right. I did zoom in to see if the glass walls went all the way to our fakie ceiling. And? And they did. Oh!
然后墙壁很快就安装好了。他们确实安排了我们的拍摄日程，这样我们在本周晚些时候之前就不会在吉姆的办公室里面拍摄。这主要是为了让布景师能够对其进行装饰。没错。我确实放大看了看玻璃墙是否一直延伸到我们的假天花板。然后呢？然后它们真的延伸到了。哦！
The top part is frosted, like these frosted rectangles. And then the bottom part is clear glass with blinds. Wow. Well, Randy mentioned that the new office was kind of right behind Creed's area. They didn't have to modify anything that was existing. It just kind of fit. That's what she said. There was one piece of set dressing that Randy pointed out that he says you can't see in the episode, but he absolutely loves it.
顶部是磨砂的，就像这些磨砂长方形一样。底部是透明玻璃，配有百叶窗。哇。嗯，兰迪提到新办公室差不多就在克里德区域的正后方。他们不需要修改任何现有的东西。它只是刚好合适。办公室风云就是这么说的。兰迪指出了一个布景，他说你在这一集中看不到，但他非常喜欢。
He sent us a picture of it, which is Jim's diploma. What's it say? It's just, you know, that he graduated from college. It was created by our graphics designer, Ryan Cosgrove. So we can post that in Office Lady Stories. Oh, fun. That was your breakdown of Jim's Cube. Well, you know, I noticed a few things in Jim's Cube. Oh, yeah?
他给我们发了它的照片，也就是吉姆的毕业证书。上面写着什么？也就是，你知道的，他大学毕业了。它是由我们的平面设计师瑞安·科斯格罗夫制作的。所以我们可以把它发到办公室女郎的故事里。哦，真有趣。那是你对吉姆的方块的细分。好吧，你知道，我在吉姆的方块里注意到了一些事情。哦，是吗？
Mm-hmm. I noticed a calendar, which seems important. But did you see the giant poster of a train? Yeah. What's that? And then I thought, is there a train club at Dunder Mifflin we don't know about? I mean, Dwight and Toby love trains. We learned that in the meeting.
嗯-嗯。我注意到了一个日历，这似乎很重要。但你看到那个巨大的火车海报了吗？看到了。那是什么？然后我想，邓德米夫林公司里是不是有一个我们不知道的火车俱乐部？我是说，德怀特和托比喜欢火车。我们在会议上知道了这一点。
Is there a train-finers thing club? Oh my gosh. A train club? I don't know. These are now three people at Dunder Mifflin that clearly have a thing for trains. I'm just saying. I see a theme. I took a picture of the train.
有没有一个火车迷俱乐部？哦，天哪。一个火车俱乐部？我不知道。邓德米夫林现在有三个人明显对火车有情结。我只是说说而已。我看到了一个主题。我拍了火车的照片。
I zoomed in. I couldn't make out. There's some kind of like saying underneath the train. I really wish I could have made that out. If you guys caught it, let us know. I just want to say, Ange, I feel like maybe you're the person who has a thing for trains. No, I don't. You zoomed in on a picture of a train to see what model it was, and then you Googled all
我放大了。我辨认不出来。火车下面有某种标语。我真的很希望我能辨认出来。如果你们发现了，请让我们知道。我只想说，安吉，我觉得也许你就是那个对火车有情结的人。不，我没有。你把一张火车的照片放大，想看看它是什么型号，然后你在谷歌上搜索了
the models of the trains from the meeting. I just feel like maybe, maybe you're projecting, do you love trains? Listen, first of all. Dig deep. They really think hard. First of all, how dare you? And yes, I do love trains. Secondly, whenever I see a train on a road trip, I get really excited.
会议上所有火车的型号。我只是觉得也许，也许你在投射，你喜欢火车吗？听着，首先。深入挖掘。他们真的很努力地思考。首先，你怎么敢？是的，我确实喜欢火车。其次，每当我自驾游看到火车时，我都超级兴奋。
And I pointed out to the kids, I say, look, train, look at the train. My uncle was a conductor of a train. Lady, this is a breakthrough. But come on. Jim has one poster in this whole little glass cube, and it's of a train. Of course I'm going to notice that. I mean, I just assumed it was like some leftover poster and storage, and he was like, sure. You're right.
我把它指给孩子们看，我说，看，火车，看那个火车。我叔叔以前是个列车长。女士，这是一个突破。但是拜托。吉姆在整个小玻璃方块里只有一张海报，那就是一辆火车。我当然会注意到这一点。我的意思是，我只是以为那是仓库里剩下的某张海报，而他就像是，行吧。你说得对。
You're right. Jim is probably not attached to it at all. I'm going to get you a picture of a train next year for Christmas. Are you really? Maybe. You know what I've always wanted to do? What? Is take the train.
你说得对。吉姆可能对它一点感情也没有。我明年圣诞节要给你买一张火车的照片。真的吗？也许吧。你知道我一直想做的是什么吗？什么？坐火车。
Through Scotland? Yes. Yes. I want to do that. I want to do that too, but I'm afraid I won't sleep well, and I'll just like be grouchy the whole trip. You know I don't do good without sleep. Lady, the Queen of England does it.
穿过苏格兰？对。对。我想做那个。我也想这样做，但我害怕我睡不好，而且整个旅程都会脾气暴躁。你知道我睡眠不好就不行。女士，英国女王就这么做。
You can do it. The Queen of England has a fancy train car. Well, that's true. Would I take the Queen of England's train car through Scotland? Sure. Definitely. I want to go. I want to do it.
你能做到。英国女王有一节豪华列车车厢。嗯，那是真的。我会坐英国女王的火车车厢穿过苏格兰吗？当然。绝对会。我想去。我想去。
You have to do it with me. All right, I will. You and your little succulent can ride the train. Thank you, because I'll jump in something I see with you at the end. Yay! This is great. Done. And then we can make a Hallmark movie about it.
你必须和我一起去。好吧，我会的。你带着你的小多肉植物可以坐火车。太好了，因为最后我会和你一起跳进某个地方。耶！太棒了。一言为定。然后我们可以拍一部关于它的霍尔马克电影。
Two ladies in a succulent. Traveling through Scotland. To jump in an icy cold pond. Tune in. This is a Hallmark movie. It's going to go with Laundry and Betrayal. Oh, God, I really want that to happen. We should really be producers.
两个带着多肉植物的女人。穿过苏格兰旅行。去跳进一个冰冷的池塘。收看。这是一部霍尔马克电影。它要和《洗衣与背叛》一起播。哦，天哪，我真的很想让它发生。我们真的应该当制作人。
All right, I'm going to move us on to FastFact number two. We should run a network for boring middle-aged women. Okay, move us on, move us on. FastFact number two, this episode was originally titled Co-Managers. It aired on October 1st, 2009, when it was retitled The Promotion. Here's something crazy. I was in a movie called The Promotion. I know!
好吧，我要把我们带到趣味事实二。我们应该为无聊的中年妇女开办一个网络。好了，推进，推进。趣味事实二，这一集最初命名为《联席经理》。它于2009年10月1日播出，当时被重新命名为《升职》。这里有一件疯狂的事。我曾演过一部名为《升职》的电影。我知道！
It was released in 2008. It starred John C. Reilly and Sean William Scott as these two guys who are dueling for the same job as a grocery store manager. We shot it in Chicago. You know what I had to do in order to shoot that movie? I would shoot on the office all during the week, Monday through Friday. I would get on an airplane, take the red eye to Chicago, sleep on the plane. I would work Saturday and Sunday on the movie, take the red eye back to LA, and just go to
它于2008年上映。由约翰·C·赖利和肖恩·威廉·斯科特主演，他们是两个争夺同一家杂货店经理职位的人。我们在芝加哥拍摄的。你知道为了拍那部电影我不得不做什么吗？我整周都在办公室拍摄，周一到周五。我会坐上飞机，坐红眼航班去芝加哥，在飞机上睡觉。我在周六和周日拍电影，坐红眼航班回洛杉矶，然后直接去
work on the office. One morning on a Monday after I had done this, I was in a wardrobe fitting and I fell asleep standing up. I was so tired. It was insane. That's the kind of stuff you can do when you're young and I couldn't do that today. For sure. Lady, guess what?
办公室上班。做完这一切后的一个星期一早上，我在试装时站着睡着了。我太累了。这太疯狂了。这就是你年轻时能做的事，我今天可做不到了。确实。女士，你猜怎么着？
What? I remembered that you were in a movie called The Promotion and I looked through my digital clutter and guess what I found? What? I went to your premiere. Oh yeah! And not only did I go, Ed Helms and I carpooled. Oh my gosh.
什么？我想起你演过一部叫《升职》的电影，我在我的数字杂物中翻找了一下，你猜我找到了什么？什么？我去看了你的首映式。哦，耶！而且不仅我去了，埃尔·赫尔姆斯和我拼车了。哦，天哪。
I found our emails back and forth about like who would pick up who or who could drive who and Ed said all good. He came and picked me up. He said let me know what time and I'll pick you up and maybe I can meet Isabel. That is so sweet. Because Isabel was only a few weeks old. Your premiere was May 28th, lady. And she was born May 3rd.
我找到了我们来回发的电子邮件，关于谁去接谁或者谁能开车，埃尔说一切都好。他来接了我。他说告诉我几点，他会来接我，也许他能见到伊莎贝尔。太甜了。因为伊莎贝尔当时只有几周大。你的首映式是5月28日，女士。她出生于5月3日。
You came to my movie premiere just a few weeks after your baby was born? Yes. This is something I did not appreciate at the time because I was not a mother yet. Well I looked to see if there were any photos and in our emails Ed and I were meeting up with Rachel Harris and we were all going to go and I found photos of Rachel Harris. I found photos of Malora, Oscar and Kate all at your premiere. Not a single photo of me and Ed. I don't know.
你在你的孩子出生几周后就去参加我的电影首映式了？是的。这是我当时没有感激的事，因为我当时还不是母亲。好吧，我查看了是否有任何照片，在我们的电子邮件中，埃尔和我正与瑞秋·哈里斯会合，我们都要去，我找到了瑞秋·哈里斯的照片。我找到了马洛拉、奥斯卡和凯特的照片，都在你的首映式上。没有一张我和埃尔的照片。我不知道。
I don't know if we were running late. I don't know if because I had just had a baby. I was like yeah no I'm not walking that red carpet. But we did go and we carpooled. Oh well I really appreciated that. I loved being in that movie. I made a really good friend on that movie in Fred Armisen. He had another supporting role so we had a lot of down time together.
我不知道我们是不是迟到了。我不知道是不是因为我刚生了孩子。我就想，好吧，不，我才不走那个红地毯呢。但我们确实去了，而且我们拼车了。哦，好吧，我真的很感激。我喜欢那部电影。我在那部电影里交到了一个非常好的朋友，弗莱德·阿米森。他有另一个配角，所以我们有很多一起闲逛的空闲时间。
We hung out a lot and he was one of the people like you who really took care of me in New York when I broke my back and yeah that was, I loved that movie. I loved it too. Fred is one of the funniest people I've ever met in my life. And Jenna you and I have worked with a lot of funny people so that is saying a lot. But I remember one time coming over and hanging out with you and Fred and I was crying. I was laughing. Like I was laughing so hard I couldn't catch my breath.
我们经常在一起，他就像你一样，在我摔断背部时在纽约真正照顾我的人之一，是的，我爱那部电影。我也很爱它。弗莱德是我一生中见过的最有趣的人之一。詹娜，你和我合作过很多有趣的人，所以这说明了很多。但我记得有一次过去和你还有弗莱德一起玩，我在哭。我在笑。就像我笑得喘不过气来。
Just did him just riffing about. I don't know what we were talking about just random stuff. But he's so flippin funny. No him and Chris Parnell. Oh forget it. Forget it. I can't. Yeah.
就是他即兴发挥关于。我不知道我们在聊什么，就是一些随机的事情。但他太滑稽了。不，他和克里斯·帕内尔。哦，算了。算了。我不能。是的。
It's too much. Chris Parnell and Fred Armisen will you be in our movie where we travel with a succulent through Scotland? We would just laugh the whole time. It would be wonderful. I want that experience. All right. Are you ready for fast fact number three? Yes.
太夸张了。克里斯·帕内尔和弗莱德·阿米森，你们愿意加入我们的电影，带着一株多肉植物穿过苏格兰旅行吗？我们一路上都会笑个不停。那会太棒了。我想要那种体验。好的。你准备好听趣味事实三了吗？准备好了。
Jen Salada as I said was our writer-director. And I reached out to her because I noticed that this episode is basically just one big A story. Like including the cold open. It's not even like a standalone cold open. It's an on plot cold open. Yeah. It's one big story start to finish. There's no B story.
詹·萨拉达，正如我所说，是我们的编剧兼导演。我联系了她，因为我注意到这一集基本上就是一个大的A线故事。就像包括冷场开场在内。它甚至不像一个独立的冷场开场。这是一个融入剧情的冷场开场。是的。这是一个从头到尾的大故事。没有B线故事。
There's this little bitty runner about Pam and her registry. But here's what Jen had to say about that. I think because it was a bigger story for Michael and Jim and a story which affected everyone in the office. We opted for no B story on this one. But I noticed when I rewatched it that a lot of the how it affected everyone in the office didn't make it into the episode. There were some really fun talking heads about who everyone preferred as a boss, Michael or Jim. But they didn't make it in. I love the small money runner for Pam.
有一个关于帕姆和她婚礼登记处的微小支线。但詹对此有何看法：我认为因为这是一个关于迈克尔和吉姆的更大故事，也是一个影响到办公室里每个人的故事。我们选择在这个故事中没有B线故事。但我重看时注意到，很多关于它如何影响办公室里每个人的情节并没有进入这一集。有一些非常有趣的单人访谈，关于每个人更喜欢谁作为老板，迈克尔还是吉姆。但它们没有被剪进去。我喜欢帕姆的小金钱支线。
The moment you see your new last name on the check was my favorite. I like how different it felt in this episode to see Jim in his own office. You'd imagine Jim having his own office would be a nice thing. But then it separates him out from the others in a way that Michael has also separated out. So there's definitely good and bad in this promotion. I always love when writers speak thematically about an episode. I'm real nerdy like that. I just love how smart they are.
支票上出现你新姓氏的那一瞬间是我的最爱。我喜欢在这一集中看到吉姆在自己的办公室里那种不同的感觉。你会想象吉姆有自己的办公室会是一件美好的事。但随后它以一种迈克尔也被隔离的方式将他与其他人隔离开来。所以这次升职肯定有好有坏。我总是喜欢编剧们以主题的方式谈论一集。我就是那种死宅。我只是喜欢他们有多聪明。
And I just loved it. I know. I'm just like, haha, this is so funny. And they're like, I'm going to break down how this comedy works. Yeah, exactly. Well, Jen is right. There are a lot of deleted scenes. I really enjoyed them. I'm going to share a few later in the episode where they would have come.
我太喜欢了。我知道。我只会说，哈哈，这太有趣了。而他们却说，我要剖析这个喜剧是如何运作的。是的，完全如此。嗯，詹说得对。有很多被删减的片段。我真的很喜欢它们。我稍后会在这一集里分享一些它们本来应该出现的地方。
But there's maybe just a little teaser here. My favorite Stanley talking head ever that got deleted. Oh, it's going to come later. But yeah, if you have the DVDs, go to the deleted scenes for this one because they are delicious. Well, lady, that's all I've got. I think we could take a break and then we'll get into it. Let's do it. All right.
但这里可能只有一个小预告。我最喜欢的斯坦利单人访谈被删掉了。哦，它会晚点出现。但是，如果你有DVD，去看这一集的被删减片段，因为它们太棒了。好吧，女士，这就是我所有的内容了。我想我们可以休息一下，然后我们再深入探讨。我们开始吧。好的。
This episode starts with Dwight needing a signature for an expense report from Michael. But Michael says, you know what? That doesn't fall under his category of boss, right? He's big picture and he sends him to Jim. And poor Dwight now is a ping pong ball going back and forth between these two guys. Yeah. Jim is kind of like, hmm, I don't know. I'll sign it, but only if you say please. So then Dwight tries to file a report on Jim.
这一集开始时，德怀特需要迈克尔在一份费用报告上签字。但迈克尔说，你知道吗？这不属于他作为老板的类别，对吧？他是大局观，他把德怀特打发到吉姆那里。可怜的德怀特现在就像一个在这两个人之间来回弹的乒乓球。是的。吉姆有点像，嗯，我不知道。我签字，但前提是你得说请。于是德怀特试图对吉姆提起报告。
Oh, it's a mess. This co-manager thing is a mess. It's already a mess. Dwight has a talking head where he shares what he'd like to do to Jim, put him in a triangle, choke hold for some down. He basically, Dwight wants to be like a professional wrestler, right? Is that what's happening here? That's what he's describing.
哦，这太乱了。这个联席经理的事真是一团糟。已经是一团糟了。德怀特有一个单人访谈，分享了他想对吉姆做什么，把他弄进一个三角锁喉里进行一些摔跤。他基本上，德怀特想成为一个职业摔跤手，对吧？这正是这里发生的事情吗？这就是他所描述的。
Yeah. Well, I have a couple of observations about this cold open. Okay. Number one, Jim is suited up. Well, yeah. He's got his ambition jacket back on again. He's super serious. He's boss, man.
是的。嗯，我对这个冷场开场有几个观察。好的。第一，吉姆穿戴整齐。嗯，是的。他又穿上了他的雄心壮志夹克。他超级严肃。他是老板。
He's boss. Dwight is not wearing mustard. Did you notice? Oh my God. Yeah. I mean, I didn't, but now I, yeah. He's also in a full suit and his shirt is like this blue, gray, green color.
他是老板。德怀特没有穿芥末黄。你注意到了吗？哦，天哪。是的。我的意思是，我没有，但现在我，是的。他也穿着全套西装，他的衬衫是这种蓝灰绿色的。
Very interesting. Cause he's vying for the position. Perhaps. So he has to look serious. Another observation about this cold open actually comes from our writer director, Jen Salada. And she talks a little bit about what it was like to shoot. Here's what she said.
非常有趣。因为他在竞争这个职位。也许吧。所以他必须看起来很严肃。关于这个冷场开场的另一个观察实际上来自我们的编剧兼导演詹·萨拉达。她谈到了一点拍摄时的感受。她是这样说的。
I always really respected the directors that would play by the two-camera doc rule that was established early on. Many did, but I really remember Jeff Blitz always sticking to that rule. There were so many good and beautiful episodes where you could feel the presence of more than two cameras, but I loved when directors would have to reach to get what they wanted using only the two.
我一直非常尊重那些遵循早期确立的两人摄像机纪录片规则的导演。很多人都这样做了，但我真的记得杰夫·布里茨一直坚持这个规则。有那么多精彩绝伦的剧集，你能感受到两个以上摄像机的存在，但我更喜欢导演们不得不绞尽脑汁仅用两个摄像机来实现他们想要的东西。
I tried hard to figure out a way to lose the third camera and that cold open when Dwight was running back and forth between Michael and Jim's office, but I never cracked it and it still kind of bugs me. It's so funny. I didn't even notice. I didn't either, but I, you know, I do remember Jeff Blitz really trying to stick to a traditional documentary.
当德怀特在迈克尔和吉姆的办公室之间跑来跑去时，我曾努力寻找一种去掉第三个摄像机的方法，但我从未破解它，它现在仍然让我有点烦恼。太搞笑了。我甚至都没注意到。我也没有，但是，你知道，我确实记得杰夫·布里茨真的很努力地坚持传统的纪录片风格。
I remember that about him. Well, he was a documentarian. Yeah. You know, so that makes sense to me. And I know that Jen worked really closely with him, so it also makes sense to me that she would want to adhere to it as well. Yeah. Well, I guess if you rewatch that cold open, you can look for the
我对他的这一点印象深刻。嗯，他本来就是个纪录片导演。是的。所以这对我来说说得通。而且我知道詹跟他合作得很紧密，所以她也想坚持这一点对我也说得通。是的。嗯，我想如果你重看那个冷场开场，你可以寻找
three camera angles instead of two, but I have to say Jen, I didn't see it. So you tricked me. You got us. So now we're going to get into this episode and Michael wants everyone to gather in the conference room. He wants to have a meeting and he suggests that everyone bring a snack because this meeting might take a while.
三个摄像机角度而不是两个，但我必须说，詹，我没看出来。所以你把我骗了。你把我们都骗了。现在我们要进入这一集，迈克尔想让大家聚集在会议室里。他想开个会，他建议每个人都带点零食，因为这个会议可能需要一段时间。
Oh Lord. And Jim is like, Michael, can I speak to you in my office? And Michael is like, maybe you can come speak to me in my office. And then Stanley says, wait, can I be a boss too? Yes. And then Oscar has a talking head where he says it doesn't take a genius to know that an organization thrives with two
哦，天哪。吉姆说，迈克尔，我能在我的办公室跟你谈谈吗？迈克尔说，也许你可以来我的办公室跟我谈谈。然后斯坦利说，等等，我也能当老板吗？是的。然后奥斯卡有一个单人访谈，他说不用天才也能知道一个组织在两个
leaders. Lady, I looked up some organizations that have two CEOs. Oh. And guess what? Not the popes, I'm guessing. No, not the popes. Who? Netflix.
领导者的带领下会蓬勃发展。女士，我查了一些有两个首席执行官的组织。哦。你猜怎么着？我猜不是教皇吧。不，不是教皇。那是谁？网飞。
Okay. Warby Parker. Oh. Sales force. There's a very successful meal delivery service called Fresh and Lean. And most notably, Ramble, our company. Woo hoo.
好的。沃比·帕克。哦。赛富时。有一家非常成功的送餐服务公司叫Fresh and Lean。最引人注目的是，Ramble，我们的公司。呜呼。
We are co CEOs. And by the way, our organization is thriving with two leaders. Oscar, you got it wrong. We are doing great. So this really starts a whole bunch of deleted scenes that Jen was talking about. One of them involves Kevin. Just in the fact that he doesn't know how to relate to Jim
我们是联合首席执行官。顺便说一句，我们的组织在两位领导者的带领下蓬勃发展。奥斯卡，你弄错了。我们做得很好。这确实引出了詹一直在谈论的一大堆被删减的片段。其中一个涉及凯文。仅仅是因为他不知道如何把吉姆
anymore as a boss. Jim was his buddy, right? And it's really funny. He ends up over sharing a whole bunch of things he shouldn't be saying to a boss. We have to hear it. I just wanted to congratulate you on your promotion. Oh, thanks.
再当作老板来相处。吉姆是他的哥们，对吧？这真的很好笑。他最后过度分享了一大堆他不应该对老板说的事情。我们得听听。我只是想祝贺你升职。哦，谢谢。
Yeah. And also I was wondering if you could forget what I said last week about the fact that I don't really do my job. Oh, sure. Is that why you've been avoiding me? Oh, no. I wouldn't do that. Oh, it was just that I was late today and I took a nap in the
是的。还有我想知道你能不能忘掉我上周说的话，关于我其实没有好好工作的事。哦，当然。这就是你一直躲着我的原因吗？哦，不。我不会那样做。哦，只是我今天迟到了，我在
bathroom for a while. All right. I think you're going to want to stop telling me those things. Gotcha. I will stop telling you things. Oh, that kind of breaks my heart. I know. But also, how often is Kevin napping in the bathroom?
洗手间里睡了一会儿。好吧。我想你不会想再告诉我这些事情了。知道了。我不再告诉你事情了。哦，那有点让我心碎。我知道。但话说回来，凯文在洗手间里打盹有多频繁？
Exactly. So Jim ultimately decides, I guess, he will go into Michael's office, right? He won't make Michael come into his. And right when he sits down to talk to Michael, I caught a little background surfing the internet. Oh my gosh, me too. It's at four minutes, 12 seconds.
没错。所以吉姆最终决定，我想，他会走进迈克尔的办公室，对吧？他不会让迈克尔走进他的办公室。就在他坐下来和迈克尔谈话时，我发现背景里有人在上网。哦，天哪，我也是。在4分12秒的时候。
It's also at three minutes, 34 seconds. And it's Rainn Wilson. Oh, I caught myself scrolling the internet. Did you really? Yes. I caught Rainn and you caught, you guys are both surfing the internet during this whole scene. We really are.
也在3分34秒的时候。那是雷恩·威尔逊。哦，我发现自己在刷网页。你真的吗？是的。我抓住了雷恩，你抓住了，你们俩在整个场景中都在上网。我们真的是。
That's hilarious. This is the scene where Michael calls Jim, Jim, James, Jimmethy. He's like, oh, that just sounds weird. Can I go back to Jim? So Jimmethy is explaining that these conference room meetings are eating up like a large part of the day. They're very disruptive and Michael's like, you know what
太搞笑了。这就是迈克尔叫吉姆，吉姆，詹姆斯，吉姆蒂的那个场景。他说，哦，听起来怪怪的。我能叫回吉姆吗？所以吉姆蒂在解释说这些会议室会议占去了这一天的大部分时间。它们非常具有干扰性，而迈克尔却说，你知道
else eats up a large part of the day napping. You fall asleep, you wake up at its evening. Yeah. So I'll tell you what, Angela, this is a delightful scene. It's very funny. But all I noticed in this scene was the blooming plant behind Jim. Yes, I did too.
还有什么占去了这一天的大部分时间吗？打盹。你睡着了，醒来时已经是晚上了。是的。所以，我告诉你吧，安吉拉，这是一个令人愉快的场景。非常搞笑。但我在这个场景中唯一注意到的是吉姆身后那株开花的植物。是的，我也注意到了。
I had to Google it. I had to know what is this plant. You know what it is? Yes, I do. It is a piece, Lily. Aka the closet plant. I found out it is very popular in homes and offices because they don't need a ton of light or water.
我不得不去谷歌搜索。我必须知道这是什么植物。你知道它是什么吗？是的，我知道。它是一株白掌。也就是所谓的衣帽间植物。我发现它在家庭和办公室里非常受欢迎，因为它们不需要大量的光照或水。
So when I realized I would be podcasting in my closet this week, I got myself a piece, Lily. That's my plant that you noticed. Oh, I did notice. No, it's not blooming because if it's blooming, it's got, it's white with like a little yellow thing. And that's how you can tell. Yes, it is not bloomed yet, but it's substantial in size.
所以当我意识到这周我将在衣帽间做播客时，我给自己买了一株白掌。这就是你注意到的那株植物。哦，我确实注意到了。不，它没有开花，因为如果它开花了，它会有，它是白色的，还有一个小黄色的东西。这就是你如何分辨的。是的，它还没开花，但它体型相当大。
And I have to say it's really making my closet experience better. I think it's beautiful. Give it a little bit of sunlight. It likes a little bit. I have one in my backyard and it just will bloom spontaneously. I just love it so much.
我不得不说它真的让我的衣帽间体验变得更好了。我觉得它很漂亮。给它一点阳光。它喜欢一点阳光。我后院有一株，它就会自发地开花。我太喜欢它了。
And it's blooming right now. You have it planted in the ground? No, no, no. I have it in a pot. But outside? I have it outside in a pot. It's in a sort of shady part of my backyard. And I also have it near some hydrangeas.
它现在开着花呢。你把它种在地里了？不，不，不。我把它种在盆里。但在外面？我在外面用花盆养着它。它在我的后院一个比较阴凉的地方。而且它附近还有一些绣球花。
Well, let me tell you what, when I called my local nursery to ask them if they had a piece, Lily, because I wanted to buy one, they gave me a little sass. They did? Yes. First off, they said, oh, yes, we do. And I said, great. So when I get there, you know, this nursery is big.
好吧，我告诉你，当我打电话给当地的花圃问他们是否有白掌时，因为我想买一盆，他们对我有点傲慢。他们有吗？是的。首先，他们说，哦，是的，我们有。我说，太好了。所以当我到那里时，你知道，这个花圃很大。
I said, where will I find it? Is it in the outdoor section? Because most of it is like an outdoor nursery. And they sassed me and said, no, it would be in the indoor section because it's an indoor plant. It is an indoor plant. They are not wrong. I would normally put a piece, Lily, outside, guys, but I was
我说，我在哪里能找到它？它在室外区吗？因为大部分地方就像一个室外花圃。他们对我很不客气地说，不，它在室内区，因为它是一种室内植物。它是一种室内植物。他们没有错。女士们，我通常会把白掌放在外面，但我
given a gift of a pot full of a bunch of different plants and none of them had bloomed yet. And it wasn't doing so great in my kitchen window where I put things. So I set it outside in this little shady nook where my hydrangeas are happy. And voila, I have a piece, Lily, outside. Wow.
收到了一盆里面有各种不同植物的礼物，而且它们都没有开花。而且它在我厨房窗户里长得不是很好，我把东西放在那里。所以我把它放在外面那个绣球花很开心的小阴凉角落里。瞧，我在外面有一株白掌。哇。
Wow. Well, the next time I go to my nursery, I'm going to tell them that story because the lady who ended up helping me when I got there was amazing. I mean, she knew everything about plants. I feel like she would want to know. I feel like she and I would be friends. Oh, lady, actually, now that you mentioned it, I should bring
哇。好吧，下次我去我的花圃时，我要把那个故事讲给他们听，因为我到那儿时最终帮我的那个女士太棒了。我的意思是，她对植物无所不知。我觉得她会想知道的。我觉得她和我会成为朋友。哦，女士，实际上，既然你提到了，我应该带
you there because you and this woman would hit it off. I mean, maybe I shouldn't bring you there because I might lose a BFF. I mean, the two of you are total plant nerds. I love her. She's not the person who answered the phone, by the way. She did not sass me. She was wonderful.
你去那里，因为你和这位女士会很合得来。我的意思是，也许我不应该带你去，因为我可能会失去一个闺蜜。我的意思是，你们两个完全是植物书呆子。我喜欢她。顺便说一句，她不是那个接电话的人。她对我一点也不傲慢。她太棒了。
She wasn't snarky phone person. Well, I want to meet her. I can't wait. It's a plant date. It's a plant date. All right. The next scene, Pam is eyeing a donut in the kitchen and Phyllis enters, kind of asks her what she's doing.
她不是那个刻薄的接电话的人。好吧，我很想见她。我等不及了。这是一次植物约会。这是一次植物约会。好的。下一个场景，帕姆在厨房里看着一个甜甜圈，菲利斯进来了，有点问她在做什么。
I loved the scene so much. It's so funny. I mean, what the heck? Phyllis has a cousin that makes romantic birdhouse mailboxes. What is a romantic birdhouse mailbox? Are the birds making out? Like, what are they doing? Why is it romantic?
我太喜欢这个场景了。太搞笑了。我的意思是，搞什么鬼？菲利斯有个表亲制作浪漫的鸟屋信箱。什么是浪漫的鸟屋信箱？鸟儿在亲热吗？它们在做什么？为什么它很浪漫？
I don't know. Maybe they make a heart with their beaks or something. Maybe they kiss a heart. Maybe they do. I feel like you might have one of these. I could see you having a romantic birdhouse mailbox, lady. Let me tell you, the minute I read this, I had to know. And then I found mailboxes that look like birdhouses.
我不知道。也许它们用喙拼成一个心形什么的。也许它们亲吻一颗心。也许它们会。我觉得你可能有一个。我能看出你会有一个浪漫的鸟屋信箱，女士。我告诉你，我一读到这个，就必须知道。然后我找到了看起来像鸟屋的信箱。
And I actually need a new mailbox. And I was like, Josh, and he was like, no, no. I guess I'm a little confused, though. I mean, is it going to confuse the birds? Like, are they going to try to nest in your mailbox? Or will it confuse my mail carrier and then I won't get mail? I don't know. I did want to point out at four minutes and 58 seconds,
我实际上需要一个新信箱。我就想，乔希，而他却说，不，不。不过，我想我有点困惑。我的意思是，这会搞糊涂鸟儿吗？就像，它们会试图在你的信箱里筑巢吗？还是会搞糊涂我的邮递员，然后我就收不到信了？我不知道。我确实想指出，在4分58秒时，
I am holding my favorite donut. Our craft services guys would have donuts out every morning and they always had our favorites. That one was mine. It's a cake donut with icing and sprinkles. I'm kind of wishing I'd also gotten myself a donut for my closet. I didn't think of it till just now. Wait, I have to show you.
我正拿着我最喜欢的甜甜圈。我们的后勤服务人员每天早上都会准备甜甜圈，他们总是准备我们最喜欢的。那个是我的。这是一个带有糖霜和糖粉的蛋糕甜甜圈。我有点希望我也为我的衣帽间买了一个甜甜圈。我刚才没想到。等等，我必须给你看。
I was listening to your donut selection, but I have to show you the picture of the birdhouse mailbox that I want. OK. OK. It's like a three-story birdhouse. It looks like a combo mailbox and birdhouse. It is.
我一直在听你选甜甜圈，但我必须给你看我想要的那个鸟屋信箱的照片。好。好。这就像一个三层的鸟屋。它看起来像信箱和鸟屋的结合体。确实是。
If I were a bird, I wouldn't want to move into that. It feels, I don't know. It feels like it's going to be living above a busy store. Also, though, will I just have bird poop on my mail? I don't know. I guess Jim walks out of his office and notices that there's a bunch of people missing. Where are they?
如果我是一只鸟，我可不想搬进那个里面。感觉，我不知道。感觉就像住在热闹的商店楼上一样。不过话说回来，我的邮件上是不是会有鸟粪？我不知道。我想吉姆从他的办公室走出来，注意到有一群人不见了。他们去哪儿了？
I don't know. Maybe I'll go see what Michael's up to. And he's having a sneaky meeting. Yeah. He's got Oscar Stanley, Creed, and Kelly, all sitting in chairs across his desk. Michael claims it's a product expansion focus group. They all want to go back to their desks.
我不知道。也许我去看看迈克尔在干什么。他在开一个鬼鬼祟祟的会议。是的。他让奥斯卡、斯坦利、克里德和凯利都坐在他办公桌对面的椅子上。迈克尔声称这是一个产品扩张焦点小组。他们都想回到自己的办公桌前。
And Jim says, what kind of products? What happened in here? You know, what was the last thing that was said? And Stanley said, Michael said, if you don't smell this, you're fired. This leads to a Kelly talking head where she says, she loves rivalries. Michael or Jim, Paris or Nicole, Heidi or LC, it's so fun.
吉姆说，什么产品？这里发生了什么？你知道，最后说的一句话是什么？斯坦利说，迈克尔说，如果你不闻这个，你就被解雇了。这引发了凯利的一个单人访谈，她说她喜欢竞争。迈克尔或吉姆，帕丽斯或妮可，海蒂或LC，太有趣了。
This was the beginning, Jenna, of people comparing Jim and Michael as bosses. There are a series of deleted talking heads. They are so fun. We have to hear them. Let's start with Toby's. About comparing Jim and Michael is like comparing apples and oranges.
詹娜，这是人们开始将吉姆和迈克尔作为老板进行比较的开始。有一系列被删减的单人访谈。它们太有趣了。我们必须听听。让我们从托比的开始。关于比较吉姆和迈克尔就像比较苹果和橙子。
Now I like apples. I really, really don't like oranges. Oranges are annoying and hate me. Oranges are annoying and hate me. Hmm, who's the orange? That made me laugh. Now for maybe my favorite Stanley talking head ever. And it wasn't in the episode, and I'm so sad.
现在我喜欢苹果。我真的，真的很讨厌橙子。橙子很烦人，而且讨厌我。橙子很烦人，而且讨厌我。嗯，谁是那个橙子？这逗笑了我。现在也许是我最喜欢的斯坦利单人访谈。它没有出现在这一集里，我太难过了。
You have to hear it. When you ask Jim a question, he'll tell you an answer. When you ask Michael a question, he'll do an imitation of you for five minutes. Then he'll show you three YouTube videos. Then he'll try to tickle you. And if that's not enough, he'll ask you to repeat the question. Meanwhile, he's wandered off somewhere.
你必须听听。当你问吉姆一个问题时，他会告诉你一个答案。当你问迈克尔一个问题时，他会模仿你五分钟。然后他会给你看三个YouTube视频。然后他会试图逗你笑。如果这还不够，他会让你重复这个问题。与此同时，他已经走到别处去了。
He comes back, looks at the clock and leaves for the rest of the day. But he also doesn't care if you come in late. So I prefer Michael. That is amazing. I love that he said first he'll do an impression of you. Then he'll show you YouTube videos. They just cracked me up. Lastly, you have to hear Andy's comparison of Jim and Michael.
他回来了，看了一眼时钟，然后就离开去过剩下的日子了。但他也并不介意你迟到。所以我更喜欢迈克尔。太棒了。我喜欢他说首先他会模仿你。然后他会给你看YouTube视频。他们简直把我笑翻了。最后，你必须听听安迪对吉姆和迈克尔的比较。
Because Andy is doing that thing, Jenna, that we do when a question makes us uncomfortable. Michael is like the fun dad. And Jim is like the serious mom. And we know Andy is stuck in the middle. But he loves the both very much. But if he had to pick one, he would probably pick Jim. Because Jim gives him his num-nums on time.
因为安迪在做那件事，詹娜，当一个问题让我们感到不舒服时我们就会做的事。迈克尔就像有趣的爸爸。吉姆就像严肃的妈妈。我们知道安迪夹在中间。但他非常爱他们两个。但如果他必须选一个，他可能会选吉姆。因为吉姆准时给他糖糖。
Num-nums are, of course, my commission checks. Oh, Andy. But we've talked about this. And sometimes you get asked a question that you're like, I don't want to, this might come across mean to someone. I'll do it a little voice or I'll sing it. Yeah, the lady at the nursery was real mean to me. Yeah, she told me peace, Lilies, have to stay inside.
糖糖，当然，是我的佣金支票。哦，安迪。但我们讨论过这个。有时你会被问到一个问题，你会想，我不想，这可能会对某人显得很mean。我会用小嗓子或者唱出来。是的，花圃里的那个对我真的很mean。是的，她告诉我白掌必须放在里面。
And I didn't like it one bit. Well, now we're going to get into the major conflict of this episode. David Wallace is going to call and explain that Dunder Mifflin cannot give out cost of living raises this year. There's a finite amount of money. And it's up to these guys to figure out how to distribute the money amongst all the employees. And Michael and Jim start vying for this.
我一点也不喜欢。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集的重大冲突。大卫·华莱士打来电话解释说，邓德米夫林今年不能发生活成本加薪了。资金是有限的。这取决于这两个人想办法在所有员工中分配资金。迈克尔和吉姆开始为此争夺。
They're like, I got it. No, I got it. And David's like, is there going to be a problem? Also, Michael, are you texting me? Oh, yeah. I guess in the end, David is like, you need to figure this out together. Terrible idea. It starts some really funny Jim and Michael scenes
他们就像，我来。不，我来。大卫就说，会有问题吗？还有，迈克尔，你是在给我发短信吗？哦，是的。我想最后大卫就像，你们需要一起把这个搞定。糟糕的主意。这引发了一些非常有趣的吉姆和迈克尔的场景
because at first Michael is acting like that. Sure, great. They can do this together. And then Jim is like, tell me how you really feel. And he goes, I hate the fact that we have to do this together. And then he's like, all I can see is your big and gross pores on your nose. Like, it gets so personal. Later, he points out his crusty eyes.
因为起初迈克尔表现得像那样。当然，太棒了。他们可以一起做这个。然后吉姆就像，告诉我你的真实感受。他说，我讨厌我们必须一起做这件事。然后他说，我能看到的只有你鼻子上的又大又恶心的毛孔。看，这变得太私人了。后来，他指出他结痂的眼睛。
Like, what, Michael? What happens to you when you get back to the corner? You just get really mean. Lady, I literally made a list of all of Michael's jabs at Jim. He also calls him Skippy at one point. Big pores, crusty eyes, Skippy. That was as far as my list went. Also, we learned that Michael hates a prose and cons list.
就像，什么，迈克尔？你回到角落时怎么了？你变得真的很刻薄。女士，我 literalmente 列出了迈克尔对吉姆的所有挖苦。他在某个时候还叫他斯基皮。大毛孔，结痂的眼睛，斯基皮。我的列表就到此为止了。此外，我们得知迈克尔讨厌利弊清单。
Oh my gosh. Hates it. Absolutely hates it. And then he has that amazing quote where he says, sometimes the smartest people don't think at all. Well, lady, I had to know. I don't know why. I just on the fly decided to Google who invented the prose and cons list.
哦，天哪。讨厌它。绝对讨厌。然后他有了那句精彩的名言，他说，有时候最聪明的人根本不思考。好吧，女士，我必须知道。我不知道为什么。我只是临时决定在谷歌上搜索是谁发明了利弊清单。
Did you really? The answer is fascinating. Oh my gosh. I want to hear it. There is an inventor of the prose and cons list. And it is Ben Franklin. What? Ben Franklin.
你真的去搜了？答案太迷人了。哦，天哪。我想听听。有一个利弊清单的发明者。那就是本·富兰克林。什么？本·富兰克林。
All right. This is where everyone thinks the prose and cons list came from. He wrote a letter in 1772 to Joseph Priestley where he described in great detail how he makes a decision. I'm going to read it to you. Every word fascinated me. He said, quote, my way, he capitalized way, by the way, his way. Okay. Frank Sinatra, we hear you.
好吧，这就是每个人认为利弊清单来源的地方。他在1772年写了一封信给约瑟夫·普里斯特利，其中详细描述了他如何做出决定。我要读给你听。每一个字都让我着迷。他说，引述，我的方式，顺便说一句，他把“方式”大写了，他的方式。好吧。法兰克·辛纳屈，我们听到了。
Is to divide a half sheet of paper by a line into two columns. Writing over the one pro and over the other con. Then during three or four days of consideration, I put down under the different headings different motives that at different times occur to me for or against the measure. When I have thus got them all together in one view, I endeavor to estimate their respective weights where I find two, one on each side that seem equal, I strike them both out.
就是在半张纸中间画一条线分成两栏。一边写赞成，一边写反对。然后在随后的三四天考虑中，我把不同时间想到的、支持或反对这项措施的各种动机写在不同的标题下。当我把它们全部放在一起一目了然时，我努力估计它们各自的权重，如果我发现两边各有一个似乎分量相当的理由，我就把它们两个都划掉。
If I find a reason pro that is equal to two reasons con, I'll strike out all three. If I judge two reasons con equal to three reasons pro, I strike out all five and thus proceed until the balance lies. And if after a day or two of further consideration, nothing new of importance occurs on either side, I can come to a determination accordingly. Then he said, I have found great advantage from this kind of equation.
如果我发现一个赞成理由等于两个反对理由，我就把这三个全划掉。如果我判断两个反对理由等于三个赞成理由，我就把这五个全划掉，以此类推，直到权衡出结果。如果在又考虑了一两天后，双方都没有出现什么新的重要情况，我就可以据此做出决定。接着他说：“我从这种平衡法中获益匪浅。”
And he said, I believe I have discovered what could be called moral or prudential algebra. He believes that he had found a mathematical equation for making a decision. Well, I can tell you right now, he would have driven Michael Scott crazy. Crazy. If he walked in and said, listen, it's going to take me three days. Yeah, with this pros and cons list to figure out what we're going to do. Michael would have been like, I'm out.
他还说：“我相信我发现了一种可以称之为道德或审慎代数的方法。”他相信他找到了一个做决定的数学方程式。好吧，我向你保证，他会把迈克尔·斯科特逼疯的。绝对会疯。如果他走进来，然后说：“听着，我要花三天时间，对，列出这些优缺点清单来弄清楚我们要怎么做。”迈克尔肯定会说：“我不干了。”
Well, when I read this, I also realized I've been doing pros and cons lists wrong, I guess. I just make lists of pros and cons and then I can see them all in one place. I didn't realize I was supposed to strike them out if I consider them to be of equal importance. I didn't realize there was a whole striking out process that Ben Franklin intended. Well, Jenna, I know you love a list. I have no doubt you've made many pro and con lists in your life. True, true.
好吧，当我读到这段时，我也意识到我以前可能一直都把优缺点清单弄错了。我只是列出优缺点，然后就能把它们都看在眼里。我没意识到如果我认为它们重要性相当，就应该把它们划掉。我没意识到本·富兰克林其实设计了一整套划掉的流程。詹娜，我知道你喜欢列清单。毫无疑问，你这辈子列过很多优缺点清单。没错，确实如此。
Well, I'll have you know, Angela. Next, Jim is going to make a pie chart of Michael's time. How Michael spends time. Yeah, it looks like he used crayon, by the way. I know. I also Googled who invented the pie chart. Did you really? Yeah.
好吧，安吉拉，我得告诉你。接下来，吉姆要做一张关于迈克尔时间的饼图。关于迈克尔是怎么花时间的。对，顺便说一句，看起来他是用蜡笔画的。我知道。我还去谷歌了一下是谁发明的饼图。真的吗？对。
Who did it? Oh, lady, also fascinating. Who knew these Googles would be so interesting? The earliest known pie chart is generally credited to William Playfair in 1801. He was a businessman, engineer and economics writer from Scotland. But get this. What? Florence Nightingale is credited with adapting the pie chart and basically making it go viral.
谁发明的？哦，天哪，这也太迷人了。谁知道这些谷歌搜索会这么有趣？现存最早的饼图通常被认为是由威廉·普莱费尔于1801年制作的。他是来自苏格兰的商人、工程师和经济学作家。但你猜怎么着。什么？南丁格尔被认为是改进了饼图并基本上让它走红的人。
Did she use it for pain? Like what's your threshold for pain? No. But it's interesting you ask that because I will remind people that Florence Nightingale is the woman who pioneered the field of nursing. She started a nursing school. She tended to wounded soldiers during the Crimean War. But she was also a pioneer in the area of statistics.
她是用它来表示疼痛吗？就像你对疼痛的阈值是多少？不是。但你这么问很有趣，因为我要提醒大家，南丁格尔是开创护理领域的女性。她创办了一所护校。她在克里米亚战争期间照顾受伤的士兵。但她也是统计学领域的先驱。
And she made a pie chart that showed the impact of poor sanitary conditions on mortality rates. And some people believe that this is the first time that a pie chart was used to persuade people to change. Oh, wow. And it kind of went viral. So she's credited as, you know, making the pie chart accessible. There you go. There you go. Well, I looked at Jim's pie chart, took a picture of it.
她制作了一个饼图，展示了不良卫生条件对死亡率的影响。有些人认为，这是历史上第一次有人用饼图来劝说人们做出改变。哦，哇。而且它有点像现在的病毒式传播。所以她被认为是让饼图变得平易近人的人。就是这样。好吧，我看了吉姆的饼图，还拍了张照片。
And you know what I thought? What? He was just procrastinating. I mean, really, how different would Jim's pie chart be from Michael's? The biggest part is in green. It's procrastinating. Then the other biggest part is yellow and it's distracting others. And then there's a tiny sliver of red for critical thinking.
你知道我在想什么吗？什么？他只是在拖延时间。我是说，真的，吉姆的饼图跟迈克尔的能有多大区别？最大的一部分是绿色的。是拖延。然后第二大的部分是黄色，那是分散他人注意力。然后还有一小条红色的，代表批判性思维。
I mean, Jim's wouldn't be that different. He's always distracted. He's procrastinating. Come on. You're so right. Jim just drew his own pie chart. Well, Jim's making pie charts. Pam is still trying to hustle up some money as wedding gifts and finally find someone
我是说，吉姆的也没什么两样。他总是分心。他在拖延。拜托。你太对了。吉姆只是自己画了个饼图。好吧，当吉姆在做饼图时，潘还在努力催收一些婚礼礼金，并终于找到一个
who's going to write her a check. Kevin, he writes her a check for $40. And he says he's going to put to love's eternal glory in the subject line. But also, you know, can you wait until you cash it till Monday? Yes. But this is the moment that Pam sees. The name Mrs. Pam Halpert for the first time. Aw.
肯给她开支票的人。凯文，他开了一张40美元的支票。他说他要在备注栏写上“致爱之永恒荣耀”。但也顺便问了一句：“你能等到星期一再去兑现吗？”可以。但这就是潘看到“帕姆·哈尔珀特太太”这个名字的时刻。啊。
She gets all excited. And I have a question. Pam is doing her talking head out in the little, I don't know, what would you call that? The vestibule, the like inner lobby from right outside the door of Dunder Mifflin? Oh, yeah. Like the entryway. Yeah. That Dunder Mifflin sign that Pam is standing next to.
她兴奋得不得了。我有个问题。潘在做她的访谈，就在那个小小的……我不知道，你该怎么称呼那个地方？那个门厅，就是邓德米夫林门外正对面的内部大堂？哦，对。就像入口处。对。潘站着旁边的那个邓德米夫林标志。
Isn't that the one that John like took and you saw him putting it in his trunk? Yeah. At the end. That's the one John stole when we wrapped. That's what I thought. I was like, oh, hey, John's got that. It is that one. Yeah.
难道那不是约翰拿走并被你看到他把它放进后备箱的那个吗？对。最后。那就是约翰杀青时偷走的那个。我就知道。当时我就想：“哦，嘿，约翰拿了那个。”就是那个。对。
Well, listen, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Jim and Michael are going to try a lot of strategies to divide up this money. And pretty much none of them are going to go well. You mean putting beans on people's faces isn't a great way to figure out if they get a raise? We'll talk about it after the break. We will. Jim and Michael are in the conference room and Jim proposes that they give the raises to the salespeople.
听着，我觉得我们该休息一下了，因为等我们回来时，吉姆和迈克尔将尝试很多策略来分配这笔钱。而且几乎没有哪个策略会顺利的。你是说把豆子贴在人们脸上的方法不是弄清谁该加薪的好办法？我们休息回来后再聊。我们会聊的。吉姆和迈克尔在会议室里，吉姆提议把加薪给销售人员。
He said, they're the ones who bring in the money and this will keep them happy. Well, Michael doesn't think that's going to go over very well. Well, these guys are going to kind of argue now. And I thought this scene was a little bit dramatic and even Jen Salata mentioned it. Here's what she had to say. When I was directing a scene with Steve and John in the conference room, I think it was the scene where Michael criticizes Jim's way of thinking and Jim tells Michael that he has weaknesses.
他说，是他们带来了钱，这能让他们保持开心。好吧，迈克尔觉得这不会太受欢迎。这些家伙现在要开始争论了。我觉得这个场景有点戏剧化，连珍·萨拉塔也提到了。她是这么说的。当我导演一场史蒂夫和约翰在会议室的戏时，我想那是迈克尔批评吉姆的思维方式、而吉姆告诉迈克尔他有弱点的戏。
He popped out of the moment and looked at us and said, I think we're doing a drama right now. It occurred to me that I wrote it kind of dramatic and their instincts were dramatic as was fitting for the scene and I was steering it in an even more dramatic way. I remember trying to push things to their edges a bit more in the sixth season. Maybe as a reaction to having done so many episodes in a row fifth season that I was looking to shake things up a little and drama is definitely where some of those scenes went. Maybe with me writing and directing, there wasn't enough quality control.
他从戏里跳了出来，看着我们说：“我觉得我们现在是在拍正剧。”我突然意识到我写得确实有点戏剧化，他们的直觉也很戏剧化，这很符合这场戏的氛围，而且我在把剧情引导得更加戏剧化。我记得在第六季时，我试图把事情推向更边缘一点。也许是因为第五季连续拍了太多集后的反应，我当时想做点改变，而正剧确实是其中一些场景的走向。也许由于我既编剧又导演，缺乏足够的质量控制。
I think I even asked Paul, like, is this too dramatic? I went into a drama, but then John and Steve and I paused and talked about the balance and landed in a really nice place, I think. I love what Steve and John did in that scene and throughout that episode. It was really fun getting to dig into the relationship in a deeper way. Yeah, I can feel that in the scene. I mean, Jim's like, you know what, Michael, here are your weaknesses. And Michael's like, oh yeah, you want to tell me my weaknesses?
我想我甚至问过保罗：“这样会不会太戏剧化了？”我确实走向了正剧，但后来约翰、史蒂夫和我停下来讨论了平衡，最后落在一个非常好的地方，我觉得。我很喜欢史蒂夫和约翰在那场戏里以及整集中的表现。能够以更深的方式深入探讨这种关系真的很有趣。对，我在那场戏里能感受到这一点。我是说，吉姆就像是，“你知道吗，迈克尔，这就是你的弱点。”而迈克尔则像是，“哦，是吗，你想告诉我我的弱点？”
Like it gets really personal not to mention Michael goes there with the crusty eyes. Yes. I really like it when our show would dare to kind of let comedy go for a second. Sometimes it was in those romantic moments. Sometimes it was emotional with all the stuff about sprinkles, all the stuff about your heart getting broken, Angela. Like I liked it when the show didn't need to be funny or ring that funny bell every three seconds, which is kind of your traditional comedy.
就像这变得非常私人化一样，更不用说迈克尔还提到了眼屎的话题。对。我真的很喜欢我们的剧敢于让喜剧暂停一秒钟。有时是在那些浪漫的时刻。有时是充满情感的，比如关于斯普林克尔的所有事情，关于你心碎的所有事情，安吉拉。我喜欢这部剧不需要每三秒钟就搞笑一次或者去敲响传统喜剧那个搞笑的钟。
So I really appreciated the scene. I did too. And of course they found like the moments of comedy. And one of the lines that made me laugh was at the very end when, you know, Jim is going to go out there. Michael's like, okay, Skippy, give it your best shot. Go tell him. And Jim leaves and then Michael turns to Cameron says, this had better be terrible.
所以我真的很欣赏这场戏。我也很欣赏。当然，他们也找到了喜剧的时刻。让我笑出来的台词之一是最后，当吉姆要走出去时。迈克尔说：“好了，斯基普，拿出你的最佳水平。去告诉他们。”然后吉姆离开了，迈克尔转过身对卡梅伦说：“这最好能糟糕透顶。”
Yeah, like he's rooting for him to fail. And when Jim does just lay it out there, he's honest. He's going to shoot everyone straight and right away it doesn't go well. Well, he comes off condescending. He's talking about, I'm going to talk to you all like adults because you're very smart. Yes. And then Oscar says, thank you, Jim, for thinking that we're smart people. And then Angela sort of playing dumb goes, but I do not understand if we're such smart
对，就像他在盼着他失败一样。而当吉姆真的直言不讳时，他是诚实的。他打算对每个人都开诚布公，但马上就不顺利了。好吧，他显得居高临下的。他说的是：“我要像对待成年人一样和你们说话，因为你们非常聪明。”是的。然后奥斯卡说：“谢谢你，吉姆，认为我们是聪明人。”接着安吉拉装傻说：“但我不明白，如果我们是这么聪明的
adults, then why don't we get raises? And Oscar's like, excellent question, genius. Also, by the way, if you go back and rewatch this, tell me if you think I sound southern when I say, I do not understand because it's all I could hear was my accent. But anyway, so the scene starts to really get out of hand and it builds with this crescendo. You've got to hear it. We work just as hard as the salespeople. We deserve raises.
成年人，那我们为什么没有加薪？”奥斯卡就说：“问得好，天才。”顺便说一句，如果你回去重看这段，告诉我你觉得我说“我不明白”时听起来有没有南方口音，因为我耳边全都是我的口音。总之，这场戏开始彻底失控，并且伴随着渐强发展。你们得听听这个。我们的工作和销售人员一样努力。我们理应加薪。
Yes. Yes. They don't get them if we don't get them. My kid needs shoes. You want to tell him he doesn't get shoes? Yeah. Our kid needs shoes, Jim. What the hell?
对。对。他们不加薪我们也没有。我的孩子需要鞋子。你想告诉他他没有鞋子穿吗？对。我们的孩子需要鞋子，吉姆。搞什么鬼？
I mean, Michael got his wish. That went terribly, terribly. Jim is going to need to rewind out of that. He's going to do his best little rewind back into the conference room. And Pam's face where she's like, oh, no, not rewind guy, not rewind guy. I went to the script and that reaction was in the script. It literally says, Pam is embarrassed for Jim. Jenna, I don't know if you remember one time when I did a rewind bit, but it killed.
我是说，迈克尔如愿以偿了。那场面简直糟糕透顶。吉姆得倒带撤出那个局面了。他得尽力倒带回到会议室里。而潘的表情仿佛在说：“哦，不，不是倒带男，不是倒带男。”我查了剧本，那个反应在剧本里。上面字面写着：潘为吉姆感到尴尬。詹娜，我不知道你是否还记得有一次我做倒带梗的时候，效果炸裂了。
Do you remember you and I? Yes, I do. I do. We co-presented at the 57th American Cinema Editors Awards and Jenna and I announced the winner of the best edited one hour series for commercial television. I did my rewind bit. Jenna, come on. It was so good.
你还记得你和我吗？是的，我记得。我记得。我们在第57届美国电影剪辑师协会奖上共同担任颁奖嘉宾，詹娜和我宣布了商业电视最佳一小时系列剧剪辑奖的得主。我用了我的倒带梗。詹娜，拜托。效果太棒了。
It was so good. Want to hear it? First of all, we had great banter. I thought we were great co-presenters. I thought we should get asked to host a whole award show based on that one appearance. I really did. I was like, I was so pleased with us that I was like, I'm sorry. Give us a call, Emmys.
太棒了。想听听吗？首先，我们互动非常棒。我觉得我们是非常棒的颁奖搭档。我觉得凭那一次亮相，我们就应该被邀请去主持一整场颁奖典礼。我真的是这么想的。当时我对我们的表现太满意了，以至于我想说：“抱歉，艾美奖，给我们打电话吧。”
We need to host the whole shebang. Or at least present one award. Yeah. Here's my editor's bit. Ready? Yeah. So we did this bit. Jenna, remember you set up how we would walk by?
我们需要主持整场盛会。或者至少颁发一个奖项。对。这是我的剪辑师梗。准备好了吗？对。所以我们演了这个梗。詹娜，还记得你铺垫了我们是怎么走过场的吗？
Yeah, I was like, we are very close with our editors. We're always walking by their edit bay and here's what we hear. And then I jumped in and went, it's so good. And it got a big laugh. We crushed it. And you folks listening out there, guess who won? The award we presented, it was none other than the editors for Friday Night Lights. So cool.
对，我说的是：我们和剪辑师关系非常好。我们总是路过他们的剪辑间，以下是我们听到的声音。然后我插话道：“太棒了。”这引起了哄堂大笑。我们大获成功。你们这些在听的听众，猜猜是谁赢了？我们颁发的奖项不是别人，正是《胜利之光》的剪辑师。太酷了。
So cool. And it was a show Jenna and I both loved. We were so excited to meet them. That was a really fun night. I found fancy photos of us. Oh, I found fancy photos of us from that night. And then also Jenna, I meant to bring up your red carpet photos for the promotion. You were all about the over the shoulder.
太酷了。而且那是詹娜和我都深爱的一部剧。我们很高兴能见到他们。那是个非常有趣的夜晚。我找到了我们当时的精美照片。哦，我找到了我们那天晚上的精美照片。还有詹娜，我本想提起你宣传时的红毯照片。你当时全神贯注于回眸姿势。
I was. You're like, tonight, tonight, I am going to finally get the over the shoulder look. Wait, I have to show you. That's very funny. You know, we did from time to time, a red carpet would come up and we'd be like, listen, I'm going to nail this new situation. I don't know what it would be like. I'm going to get the pout right tonight or I'm going to nail an over the shoulder.
我是。你当时说：“今晚，今晚我一定要拍出回眸的角度。”等等，我得给你看。这太搞笑了。你知道的，我们有时会遇到走红毯的情况，然后我们会说：“听着，我要搞定这个新局面。我不知道会是什么样。今晚我要把噘嘴的表情练好，或者我要拍出一张完美的侧身回眸。”
I clearly decided to take on over the shoulder. The promotion was your night for it. I'll put it in stories, guys. I can't wait. Well, listen, in this whole scene, we did get a fan question from Heather B and Victoria, British Columbia, Canada, who noticed when Oscar tells the office that Jim is only giving raises to his friends and the people he sleeps with, Pam turns around in her chair and mouth something in Oscar's direction.
我显然决定挑战回眸。宣传活动就是你尝试它的夜晚。我会发到快拍里的，伙计们。我等不及了。听着，在这整场戏中，我们确实收到了来自不列颠哥伦比亚省维多利亚市的Heather B和Victoria的一个粉丝提问，他们注意到当奥斯卡告诉办公室吉姆只给他的朋友和跟她上过床的人加薪时，潘在椅子上转过身去，朝着奥斯卡的方面动了动嘴唇。
It's at 13 minutes, 18 seconds. Jenna, what were you saying? Oh my God. I saw it. I'm saying Oscar, but they cut my audio and I went to the script and it was not scripted. So clearly I improvised Oscar and when they got an editing room, they were like, we are not interested in this improvisation. We're cutting your audio.
那是13分18秒。詹娜，你当时在说什么？天哪。我看到了。我在说“奥斯卡”，但他们剪掉了我的音频，我去查了剧本，那句台词根本不在剧本里。所以很明显我即兴发挥了“奥斯卡”，当他们到了剪辑室时，他们大概会想：“我们对这个即兴发挥不感兴趣。我们要剪掉你的音频。”
We're cutting you out. So anyway, after Jim rewinds back into the conference room, they still have to make this decision. Michael suggests maybe they do a merit-based raise and this is going to lead them to putting the Boston baked beans on the photos of the employees. But first, we're going to hear from the largest talking head in office history. Six people, it's at 14 minutes, 45 seconds. There is sort of a pyramid shape of office coworkers.
我们要把你剪掉。总之，在吉姆倒带回到会议室后，他们仍然得做出这个决定。迈克尔建议或许他们可以搞一个基于绩效的加薪，而这导致了他们把波斯顿烤豆贴在员工的照片上。但首先，我们要听听办公室历史上最庞大的访谈。六个人，在14分45秒。办公室同事们呈某种金字塔形状排列。
Creed at the top in the back row, Meredith, Kevin and Angela in the front row, Dwight and Oscar and they are not happy. Meredith says, I am so pissed at this company. Yeah. And then Dwight goes, I'm Jim. And Meredith said, who says that? And Dwight says, I think it was Creed. Creed's like, yep.
克里德在最后一排的最上面，梅雷迪思、凯文和安吉拉在前排，还有德怀特和奥斯卡，他们很不高兴。梅雷迪思说：“我对这家公司气疯了。”对。然后德怀特说：“我是吉姆。”梅雷迪思说：“谁说的？”德怀特说：“我觉得那是克里德。”克里德说：“对。”
Creed hadn't spoken. What's happening, Creed? I loved the big group talking head. I thought it was really fun. I did too. It was fun to shoot as well because we each had a line and it was sort of like rapid fire and it was just a ton of fun. Well, listen, Dwight is going to sneak into the conference room and he's going to discover
克里德没有说话。怎么回事，克里德？我很喜欢那个大型集体访谈。我觉得真的很有趣。我也觉得。拍起来也很有趣，因为我们每个人都有一句台词，有点像连珠炮，真的超级好听。好吧，听着，德怀特要偷偷溜进会议室，他要发现
all these little beans on everybody's face and he's going to blow their cover. I did a deep dive on Boston baked beans because why not? As you do. Here's what I'm going to let you know. Were they invented in the 14th century by... Well, first of all, I have to say, as I researched them, they sound delicious. I've never really been drawn to the Boston baked bean because the name baked bean, it doesn't like make me want to eat it as a candy.
每个人脸上的所有这些小豆子，他要揭穿他们的老底。我对波士顿焗豆做了一次深入研究，因为为什么不呢？就像你常做的那样。以下是我要告诉你的。它们是在14世纪由……好吧，首先，我必须说，当我研究它们时，它们听起来很好吃。我从来没有真正被波士顿焗豆吸引过，因为“焗豆”这个名字，它不会让我把它当成糖果来吃。
So, I mean... Wait, they're candy? They're candy. See, right? Oh, my God. I thought they were putting actual beans. No, Boston baked beans are a sugar coated peanut candy. Oh, yes.
所以，我的意思是……等等，它们是糖果？它们是糖果。你看，对吧？哦，天哪。我以为他们放的是真正的豆子。不，波士顿焗豆是一种裹着糖衣的花生糖。哦，是的。
Okay. The name Boston baked bean is a generic name used throughout the whole candy industry to mean sugar coated peanut. But the Ferrara Pan Candy Company developed their line of the Boston baked beans in the early 1930s, those are the ones in the red box that you see all the time. Right, right. They're made in this process called cold panned candy process, and the pan's kind of like moving a circle or something, almost like a record, and you throw the peanuts
好吧。“波士顿焗豆”这个名字是整个糖果行业通用的名称，指的是糖果衣花生。但是费拉拉潘糖果公司（Ferrara Pan Candy Company）在20世纪30年代初开发了他们的波士顿焗豆系列，就是你经常看到的那个红盒子里的。对，对。它们是通过一种叫做冷式滚糖果的工艺制作的，这个盘子有点像在画圆或什么的，几乎像一张唱片，你把花生
in and then like the sugar kind of coats them slowly until you get them the right size. I don't know. They sound really good. Do you need some Boston baked beans, lady? Do I need to drop some off? Maybe I do. Why did I only get a plant? Why didn't I also get Boston baked beans in a donut?
扔进去，然后糖慢慢地包裹着它们，直到它们达到合适的大小。我不知道。它们听起来真的很不错。你需要一些波士顿焗豆吗，女士？我需要送一些过来吗？也许我需要。为什么我只得到了一株植物？为什么我没有在甜甜圈里也得到波士顿焗豆？
I don't know. I did find out a few fun facts about the Ferrara Company that makes Boston baked beans that I thought was kind of cool because they make a bunch of different candies. Mm-hmm. They make 800,000 sweet tart rolls every day. It's the size of 2,700 football fields a day. Wow. They run out of Chicago.
我不知道。我确实查到了一些关于制造波士顿焗豆的费拉拉公司的趣事，我觉得挺酷的，因为他们生产各种不同的糖果。嗯哼。他们每天生产80万个甜酸卷（sweet tart rolls）。这相当于每天2700个足球场的大小。哇。他们总部设在芝加哥。
They also make nerds. Oh, the candy nerds. Yeah. And they make 135,000 pounds of nerds every day. Whoa. They also make trolley sour bright worms. Don't know what that is. They're like, you know, sour worms.
他们还生产聪明豆（nerds）。哦，那个聪明豆糖果。对。他们每天生产135,000磅的聪明豆。哇哦。他们还生产特罗利酸溜溜虫软糖（Trolley sour bright worms）。不知道那是什么。它们就像，你知道的，酸软糖。
Okay. They make 127 pounds every minute. Wow. And they are the largest producer of candy canes. And most jelly beans that are consumed in the United States are made by this company. They're very busy. And now they are a licensed Girl Scout Cookie Baker. What Girl Scout Cookie do they make?
好吧。他们每分钟生产127磅。哇。而且他们是最大的糖果手杖（candy canes）生产商。美国消耗的大多数果冻豆也是这家公司生产的。他们非常忙碌。现在他们是女童子军饼干的授权烘焙商。他们制作哪种女童子军饼干？
They make them all. They can bake them all. They're one of the licensed bakers. Oh. They have a person, Natalie Hagstrom, who is the General Manager of Cookies. That is her title. General Manager of Cookies. I kind of want that job.
他们全部都做。他们可以烘焙所有这些。他们是授权烘焙商之一。哦。他们有一个人，娜塔莉·哈格斯特罗姆（Natalie Hagstrom），是饼干总经理。这就是她的头衔。饼干总经理。我有点想要那份工作。
I want that on a business card. Me too. Right? Yeah. So that's everything I learned in my deep dive about the Boston Baked Bean. You never know, lady, what you're going to find. You never know. You never know.
我希望名片上能印这个。我也是。对吧？是的。这就是我在对波士顿焗豆的深入研究中了解到的全部内容。你永远不会知道，女士，你会发现什么。你永远不会知道。你永远不会知道。
I try to bring a lot of special facts to the podcast to make. And you do. Your dinner party conversations. Delightful. A little more interesting. That's right. Maybe so. Dwight is going to lead everyone into the conference room to show them the beans on the photos.
我试图为播客带来很多特别的事实，让……你确实做到了。你的晚宴谈话。真令人愉快。更有趣一点。没错。也许吧。德怀特将带领大家进入会议室，向他们展示照片上的豆子。
One of my favorite lines that he says was such seriousness is, they determine our worth by putting beans upon our faces. I know. And then Kevin cannot stop saying, what does a bean mean? What does a bean mean? Oscar's like, well, someone tell Kevin what a bean means. They are not happy with how they're shaking out with the beans on the faces. So after this experience in the conference room, they're back in the bullpen and Dwight
他说的我最喜欢的台词之一，带着无比的严肃，是：“他们通过把豆子放在我们的脸上来决定我们的价值。”我知道。然后凯文不停地说，“豆子代表什么？豆子代表什么？”奥斯卡就像是，“好吧，谁来告诉凯文豆子代表什么。”他们对脸上贴豆子的结果很不满意。所以在经历了会议室的这一幕后，他们回到了办公区，德怀特
is going to give a rousing speech. I mean, he is trying to form basically a mutiny against Jim in particular. Oh yeah. It's at 18 minutes, 18 seconds. He starts off with, are we idiots? What right does Jim have to claim authority? Is he as good a salesman as I? Is he as matronly as Phyllis?
将发表慷慨激昂的演讲。我的意思是，他基本上是在试图发起针对吉姆个人的哗变。哦，是的。在18分18秒。他开头就说，我们是笨蛋吗？吉姆有什么权利宣称权威？他有我一样优秀的销售能力吗？他有菲莉丝那样具有母亲般的关怀吗？
There are moments where we can affect change for a few seconds every decade we exist. And these are those seconds. Let us storm his castle. Come on, Tick. Let's get him. Tuck. Let's get Jim. Tick.
有些时刻，在我们存在的每十年里，我们可以用几秒钟的时间来影响改变。而这些就是那些时刻。让我们攻占他的城堡。来吧，滴答。我们去抓他。塔克。我们去抓吉姆。滴答。
And drag him out of his office. Tuck. Get his keys away from him, Tick. That's a clock. The time is getting very close. It's now or never. What say you? Does Dwight think he's in a Shakespearean play?
把他从办公室里拖出来。塔克。把他的钥匙从他身上拿走，滴答。那是个时钟。时间越来越近了。此时不搏，更待何时。你们怎么说？德怀特以为自己身处莎士比亚戏剧中吗？
I don't know. Of course. The speech made me think of those famous Battlecry speeches, Jenna. You know I love them. We know you love them, lady. So I just had to re-watch a whole bunch last night. What? You're just re-watching Battlecry speeches.
我不知道。当然。这个演讲让我想起了那些著名的战地演说，珍娜。你知道我爱它们。我们知道你爱它们，女士。所以我昨晚不得不把一大堆重新看了一遍。什么？你只是在重看战地演说。
You've re-watched the St. Crispin's Day speech from Henry V. I re-watched the speech in Gladiator. Oh, my God. So good. And then I forgot about the speech Kate Blanchett gives as Elizabeth the first amazing at the Battle of Tilbury. I mean, come on, Bill Paxton. In a Penn State, I had to watch a whole bunch of them.
你重看了《亨利五世》中的圣克里斯平节演讲。我重看了《角斗士》中的演讲。哦，天哪。太棒了。然后我忘了凯特·布兰切特（Kate Blanchett）在《伊丽莎白一世》中在蒂尔贝里战役中的精彩演讲。我的意思是，拜托，比尔·帕克斯顿（Bill Paxton）。在宾夕法尼亚州立大学，我不得不看一大堆。
I love them. This brought me to this conclusion. I would like to do a podcast about battle speeches. Just one episode. One episode, please. We have to. I would love it. Lady, I just love this.
我爱它们。这让我得出这个结论。我想做一个关于战斗演讲的播客。就一集。一集，拜托。我们必须这样做。我会很喜欢的。女士，我太喜欢这个了。
It's so funny because I feel like this is like, this touches in you the thing that watching like the Revenant or the Edge touches in me. I mean, it's very similar. It's just like people overcoming tough odds. I know. Everything is stacked against them. But they go anyway. Let's do it.
太有趣了，因为我觉得这就像，这触动了你内心那种看《荒野猎人》或《边缘战士》时触动我的东西。我的意思是，非常相似。这就像人们克服重重困难。我知道。一切都对他们不利。但他们还是去了。我们做吧。
I know. Well, I want to point out that at 18 minutes, 40 seconds as Dwight is giving this speech, Meredith in the background, who is very mad that she's not getting a raise. Yeah. Has free cell on her computer screen. I just have to say, Meredith, you're not making a great case for yourself. Kate Flannery, turn your screen off. During all of this rally cry, Michael sneaks into Jim's office.
我知道。嗯，我要指出的是，在18分40秒，当德怀特发表这段演讲时，背景中的梅雷迪思非常生气的她没有得到加薪。是的。电脑屏幕上正玩着空当接龙（free cell）。我不得不说，梅雷迪思，你没有为自己辩护得很好。凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery），把屏幕关掉。在这场战斗呐喊中，迈克尔偷偷溜进了吉姆的办公室。
He brings two world's best boss mugs. And guess what's inside them? Gin. Gin. Does this mean Michael has been drinking gin out of his world's best boss mug more often than we know? Maybe so. But this made me think of Paul Feig.
他带来了两个世界上最好的老板马克杯。你猜里面是什么？金酒（Gin）。金酒。这是否意味着迈克尔用他那世界上最好的老板马克杯喝金酒的频率比我们所知道的要高？也许吧。但这让我想起了保罗·费格（Paul Feig）。
Our lovely Paul Feig has his own gin. Me too. He has two babies as he calls them. He has Artingstahl gin and he has a premixed Negroni number one cocktail. It's amazing. The bottles are beautiful. That's what I wrote. I wrote not only are the bottles beautiful, but it's really good gin.
我们可爱的保罗·费格有他自己的金酒。我也是。他有两个他称之为宝贝的东西。他有阿丁斯托尔金酒（Artingstahl gin）和预调的尼格罗尼一号鸡尾酒（Negroni number one cocktail）。太棒了。瓶子很漂亮。这就是我写的。我写道，不仅瓶子很漂亮，而且这真的是很好的金酒。
We'll take a picture of ours and we'll put them in stories. Yes. And we'll put a swipe up so you can find Paul Feig's gin because it's delicious. And we love Paul. He's been working on that for a long time and you know that man loves a cocktail. He likes a fancy cocktail. He's a mixologist. Yeah.
我们会拍下我们那瓶的照片，然后发到快拍里。是的。我们会放一个上滑链接，这样你就能找到保罗·费格的金酒，因为它太美味了。我们爱保罗。他为此努力了很长时间，你知道那个男人喜欢鸡尾酒。他喜欢花式鸡尾酒。他是个调酒师。是的。
So you know it's going to be good. Jim and Michael cheers their gin. There's a knock on the door. Then there's a pounding on the door. They look at each other and Michael says, just pretend we're not here. We had a fan question about that. It's from Rachel D. in Pennsylvania. She said, when Michael and Jim are hiding in Jim's office, someone is knocking at the door.
所以你知道它会很好喝。吉姆和迈克尔用金酒碰杯。有人敲门。然后是砰砰的敲门声。他们互相看了一眼，迈克尔说，就当不在吧。我们有一个关于这个的粉丝问题。来自宾夕法尼亚州的蕾切尔·D（Rachel D.）。她说，当迈克尔和吉姆躲在吉姆的办公室里时，有人在敲门。
Who knocked? Was it a cast member or a crew member? I'll tell you. It was a crew member because the cast was not there. If you notice, all the blinds are shut, you know, on purpose, but we did not have to be in the background of that scene. We did not have to be out there. So maybe we were getting a snack. Who knows?
谁敲的门？是演员还是剧组成员？我来告诉你。是剧组成员，因为演员不在那儿。如果你注意到，所有的百叶窗都是拉上的，你知道的，是故意的，但我们不需要出现在那个场景的背景中。我们不需要呆在那里。所以也许我们去吃点心了。谁知道呢？
Maybe we were done for the day. I just know that we were not on the schedule for that one. And so it was just those two guys and they had a crew member do the knocking. Well, Jim Salada shared with us that this was one of her favorite scenes. It's when Michael smiles at the end in Jim's office and Jim is struggling and Michael finally has someone who has to go through the tough parts of being a boss with him. And Jim said that she just loved that they could hide in the boss's office together at the end of the episode. Yeah, I liked that moment too. I did too.
也许我们那天的工作已经结束了。我只知道我们的日程表上没有那一场。所以只有那两个人，他们让一个剧组成员去敲门。好吧，吉姆·萨拉达（Jim Salada）和我们分享说，这是她最喜欢的场景之一。那是迈克尔在吉姆办公室最后微笑的时候，吉姆在苦苦挣扎，迈克尔终于找到了一个必须和他一起经历当老板艰难部分的人。吉姆说她非常喜欢他们在剧集结尾时可以一起躲在老板的办公室里。是的，我也喜欢那个时刻。我也喜欢。
Well, now we're going to have this final tag at the end. Ryan's going to come into the break room where Pam is dipping her pretzels in something. What am I dipping them in? I don't remember. I don't know why I made this choice. Do you think it was some actory method choice? Like, oh, I'm pregnant. I'm probably having odd cravings.
好吧，现在我们要迎来最后一个彩蛋。瑞安要走进休息室，潘正在把她的蝴蝶结饼干（pretzels）蘸进某种东西里。我在把它们蘸进什么里？我不记得了。我不知道我为什么要做出这个选择。你觉得这是某种演员方法派的选择吗？就像，哦，我怀孕了。我可能经常有奇怪的渴望。
I'll take pretzels and dip it in something weird. Yes, I think you're right. That sounds like me. It does. Because in real life, I don't dip my pretzels in anything, so I don't know what this was. I cannot believe that Pam falls for this Ryan. Crap, Ola. I cannot believe she falls for it.
我会拿蝴蝶结饼干蘸点奇怪的东西。是的，我觉得你说得对。这听起来像我。确实如此。因为在现实生活中，我不会把蝴蝶结饼干蘸到任何东西里，所以我不知道这是什么。我真不敢相信潘会中瑞安的这套。废话，奥拉。我不敢相信她会中招。
He's like, would you rather have $100 today or $5,000 a year from now? Well, at first she says $100 today. No, I know. I know her first instincts are so right, but Ryan is such a con man and he wears her down. Well, listen, he has a guy that has an algorithm that can determine the winner of any given college basketball game. Why is Ryan still working as a temp then? So I did the math. Pam writes, Ryan, a check for $50.
他就像是，你愿意今天拿100美元还是五年后拿5,000美元？好吧，起初她说今天拿100美元。不，我知道。我知道她的第一直觉是绝对正确的，但瑞安是个骗子，他把她磨垮了。好吧，听着，他有个朋友有一个算法，可以预测任何一场大学篮球比赛的赢家。那为什么瑞安还在做临时工？所以我算了一下。潘开了一张50美元的支票给瑞安。
Kevin gave her $40 earlier. She has lost $10 today. Yep. It's not going great. Why can't Creighton Barrel just make a toaster full of cash? I don't know. We'd all register for that. We sure would.
凯文早些时候给了她40美元。她今天亏了10美元。是的。情况不太妙。为什么克拉克·巴雷尔（Cracker Barrel）就不能做一个装满现金的烤面包机呢？我不知道。我们都会去登记领取那个。我们当然会。
All right. That is the promotion. We hope you go out today and have a fantastic day full of loves, eternal glory. We're sending you big hugs. Yeah, maybe get yourself a plant. I recommend it. Maybe you need to go watch a battle cry speech, get you going for the whole week. Make a prose console and see how you feel in three days, then decide.
好的。这就是宣传。我们希望你今天出门，度过充满爱、永恒荣耀的美妙一天。我们给你一个大大的拥抱。是的，也许给自己买一株植物。我推荐。也许你需要去看一场战地演说，让你一整周都充满干劲。做个赞成与反对列表，看看你三天后的感受，然后再做决定。
Have a great week, you guys. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco.
祝你们度过美好的一周。再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 上享受免费一个月的试用，使用代码 OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。